john mccain pounded his hands into his
fist and goes god damn it gene we have
to get this [ __ ] solved this is gonna be
another [ __ ] vietnam the trump
administration negotiated the release of
five thousand of the most lethal
fighters and leaders again you see that
the president united states up today
still spewing
[ __ ] the byte administration's pro
has the blame for not having listened to
us and having planned the proper
evacuation of these people in the first
place why did we ever take a single
service member out of afghanistan before
we moved our vulnerable afghans will be
the thing that haunts me till i die
[Music]
my guest today is captain matt ziller
which probably in the last 24 to 48
hours you've heard them all over the
place and this is not just a man that's
sitting there calling out biden he's
also calling out trump it's almost
confusing where do we have this guy on
cnn because he may call out biden do we
have him on fox because he may call out
trump he called that stephen miller he
called out everybody in the last 48
hours am i kind of a guy because that's
where you actually end up getting to the
bottom of it to find out what's going on
in afghanistan what's going on in
taliban could we have done anything
differently or better so with that being
said a fellow at the truman project for
national security and adjunct fellow at
the american security project and a
former intelligence analyst matt thank
you so much for being a guest on
valuetainment thanks for having me so so
matt uh oh i've been following the story
closely but let's just assume somebody's
watching this and all of a sudden
they're like wait a minute everything i
see i see the video with the planes i
see folks trying to get on that c-17 i
see the video where the body is dropping
because they were hanging on then i see
biden did the interview with george
where you know george is asking can we
have done anything differently no then
we see biden originally when he made the
message saying we're confident about
this the afghani military has 300 000
soldiers we've trained them well the
taliban only have 75 000 there's not
going to be any issue it's going to be
fine and now we have this so can you
kind of uh bring us up to date going
back to 20 years why we went there how
did we get here today and what was the
better way of exiting afghanistan
sure so we went to afghanistan because
of 9 11. we were there to defeat al
qaeda
and to remove the taliban government and
replace it with a democratically elected
government chosen by the people
over the last 20 years our mission has
then been to train develop mentor
guide and assist the afghan state in its
growth you know in its maturation
nation building was not what we
originally went to afghanistan to do but
is ultimately what we found ourselves
doing in order to keep that
counter-terrorism submission successful
right because as long as the afghan
state is stable people like the taliban
can't use it to host groups like al
qaeda that's the thought okay so i went
in afghanistan in 2008 i was what it's
called an embedded combat advisor
so my job was actually lived on an
afghan military base i lived with 20
other americans we had just we had about
um at that point ten interpreters so
much one interpreter for every two
americans
and we partnered with them i went out
you know we went on their missions we
ate their food
i you know shared the the same toilets
like we
our interpreters lived side by side with
us and the afghans that we served with
were our brothers and sisters
um
you know i'll be honest they were
a force that
we always talked about how we were
thankful we didn't have to be them
because of how little they had
i remember went to this one outpost it
was manned by three people
there was an old man and two kids
children
uh one of the children fighters that one
of the child soldiers he claimed to be
an afghan police officer probably i had
to have been no older than 14. he had on
a uh a dolce gabbana hat that somehow he
had gotten
and
literally no shoes
uh these these like these kind of shorts
and this this weird looking shirt
it wasn't a uniform it was just things
that he had picked up but probably you
know
god only knows handy downs something he
had found on the street he was basically
in rags
his weapon couldn't fire
it didn't have a firing pin it was just
for show
and when i asked him where the taliban
he pointed at the house across the
street he said they're there and as soon
as you leave they're going to kill us
because you've stopped here to see us
and now they think that you've armed us
so you've got to leave things to like
protect us behind
i asked him when the last time he had
been paid it hadn't been in four months
they hadn't been resupplied in four
months they weren't they were running
out of food
when when that's the level of support
that you're giving and you're still
showing up to the fight daily
i mean my goodness for anyone to
question these people's dedication is is
preposterous they didn't have body armor
like we did they didn't have the
equipment like we did they weren't
supported or taken care of with the same
logistics train or with you know medical
stuff so all that is to say
i got back home from war too while while
i was in afghanistan on my 14th day in
country my interpreter this guy named
janice noire saved my life into battle
he shot and killed two taliban fighters
who were about to kill me and i made him
a promise that if i could ever play that
life debt all he had to do is ask
a year after our tour was over
i go to say goodbye to him he's my best
friend at that point i reiterate that
promise i say hey man i haven't
forgotten about this if you need
anything you call me up got it three
weeks after i get home this is now early
2009 he calls me up and he says there is
a bounty on my head
for what i did for you the taliban have
assigned a hit team they are hunting me
i need to apply for a visa and it just
so happened that at that moment congress
had created something called the special
immigration visa program for afghans
here were the conditions you had you
have given a year's worth of service
that service had to be deemed honorable
and valuable by someone like me in
uniform so a soldier in uniform had to
recommend you for the visa you had to
prove that you were in duress because of
that service that someone was trying to
harm you and your family
and so long as you could then pass the
most arduous background investigation
that our national security apparatus
could conduct you know the cia the fbi
the nsa they're all going to look into
you and after looking into you they all
say hey this person's not a threat then
they their spouse and their children
were invited to come to the united
states and they asked if i would sponsor
him for this thing i said sure thinking
naively it might take six months a year
four years later we were still waiting
for his visa
at this point he's working on a much
larger base in kabul and he calls me up
in july of 2013 and he says hey brother
i'm about to get laid off because the
americans are closing down the base and
they're giving it back to the afghan
army and the afghan army doesn't need
interpreters
one of the privileges of being an
interpreter was you got to live on the
base with which you served at so as long
as you had a job you were protected
he knew that by being laid off he was
going to have to move back home and even
though that was a mile and a half down
the road in kabul he also knew that
there was a taliban hit team that lived
just outside the front gate of the base
waiting for him
so he said you have till october to get
me my visa or i'm a dead man and at that
point i i started this large-scale
public advocacy effort i started calling
up members of congress
just cashing in any chip that i had
trying to get our country to do right by
this guy and what we ended up realizing
was that we were going to have to
publicly embarrass the government is
doing the right thing in order to get
his visa expedited that ultimately
worked and i learned firsthand upon
immigrating him here to the united
states in october of 2013 just how
difficult it was for him and his family
we i thought there'd surely be some type
of
you know government official at the
airport with us to help greet him there
and get him set up nothing i learned at
the airport i was incumbent upon finding
him a job furnishing his home finding a
place to live there i mean there was
gonna be some limited charity assistance
but it clearly wasn't gonna last more
than a month or two
so i started a gofundme page we ended up
raising 35 grand in three days for the
guy it was enough to take care of his
first years of food and rent you know
just
allow him to enjoy his family for the
first time
when i tried to give him this money he
refused to take it and he insisted that
we use it to start an organization to as
he put it do for others as you've done
for me so that was the birth of no one
left behind
he was actually very specific he looked
me in the eye and he said what about
asan in my wand latif jamshed and khabib
he was naming all the other interpreters
who had served on a little outpost back
in afghanistan with that point wanted
to try to get here and deserve to be
here
so that was the birth of no one left
behind
that was eight years and 50 000 people
ago that the organizations helped get
over here but along the way i got very
involved in this visa journey and what i
learned was that for the first four
years of the program the obama
administration it was it was willfully
mismanaged by the state department
they had an internal policy that we
we joked was called when in doubt keep
them out
the state argued that there was nothing
in the law
that compelled them to
issue a visa
that law simply required them to make
one available for application and so
what they were doing is they were
receiving people's
applications for this life-saving visa
and then rather than actually doing
anything with it they were simply taking
it and putting them into a filing
cabinet never to be looked at again
so
individuals would never have a decision
rendered and they would just sit there
and what ended up happening was was that
in addition to not making decisions when
they would briefly try to give someone a
decision on their visa they would often
deny them that visa and they would not
tell them
under the law at that point they had the
applicant had no right to learn why a
visa had been denied nor appeal that
denial this is right nine to thirteen
nine to thirteen and so this is key i
can prove it in numbers
there's a there's a website called
rapsnet wraps
if you google that rapsnet afghan sid
arrival you can see there's a an excel
spreadsheet you can show up that shows
from the state department data the
arrival of all these people going back
to 2009 by month by year
the first four years of this program
congress authorized a total of 6 000
visas they were authorized in increments
of 1500 visas a year
and those visas were tragically used
lose
meaning that if you didn't use your
allocation in a given fiscal year if
there was access at the end of the year
it didn't roll over into your inventory
it just disappeared into the
bureaucratic ether never to be seen
again
and so what ended up happening was was
that in those first four years the
program was so poorly mismanaged that
instead of giving out a potential six
thousand remember each of these visas
cover an entire family it's not one
person it's a whole family which on
average is 4.4 people so we're talking
at this point almost around 28 000
people right
instead of potentially having moved 28
000 people in this first four years we
moved a total of 897 families
897 in the year 2011 they could have
given out 1500 visas they gave out three
they moved a total of 47 people that
year
so this massive backlog started to build
up do you know why or no do we have an
answer on why
the why is because state department
argued there was nothing in the law that
compelled them to issue a decision on a
visa so all they were doing was taking
people's applications putting them into
a filing cabinet and forgetting about
them because again the attitude within
the state department was when in doubt
keep them out they didn't want these
people coming here at the time
so in 2013
janice gets here in october
he arrived on a thursday
on monday
we were invited to meet with senators
jeanne shaheen and john mccain in
senator shaheen's office on the capitol
in washington d.c
cbs news sent jan crawford to cover it
and there's a brief clip of us going in
me introducing janice to the senators
and that's going into his office
it was a private meeting no cameras
for 20 minutes we sat there and laid out
the problems with the the visa program
inherent as they were then and why it
had been so difficult for someone like
janice to get here when he clearly
should have been here within just a
couple of months of submitting an
application
john mccain pounded his hands into his
fist and goes god damn it gene we have
to get this [ __ ] solved this is gonna be
another [ __ ] vietnam
he was pissed
he was really pissed he saw this coming
and she he looked at her and he said you
have my full support whatever it takes
to get this fixed
and then he got up and he shook my hand
and he said thank you for what you're
doing and he walked out senator shaheed
at that point turned to her chief of
staff and said whatever they think needs
to happen we need to get it done
can you guys come up with a solution
now
janice's immigration attorney and i
katie reisner then went down to the
senate dining room uh which is in the
basement of the dirksen office building
its cafeteria
and we
we on a napkin sketched out what would
become the verbatim language that was
passed three weeks later and the
national defense authorization act of
2013.
and that law fundamentally changes the
sid program
because the first thing that it did was
it every applicant had the right to
appeal their denial
the second thing was that every
applicant had the right to know why
their applications were being denied in
the first place by the way once we
learned that do you know what we learned
was the most common denial up until that
moment what's that the first four years
they had misspelled their transliterated
name
there's no standard naming convention
for the name muhammad in the u.s
government is it
m-u-h-a-m-m-e-d is it m-o-h-a-m out of
here
like you can think about all the various
ways to spell muhammad there's no
standard way to name people who are not
using english script and what the state
department had been claiming was because
they had spelled their name and
misspelled it somewhere else that they
were purposely trying to you know hide
their identity let me ask you is the
concern that the wrong person could come
in here and harm the country like hey
let's not take the risk because we don't
want another person to come and cause
another 911. exactly that exactly that
now what you need to know
is that this program has been around
both for iraqis and afghans now since
2008 in some form in that time our
country has welcomed just under 90 000
people not a single one has ever been
tried convicted arrested inter
investigated for any type of material
supports any type of terrorism they are
our most patriotic immigrants they many
of them go on to rejoin the u.s military
formally
uh and they all become citizens under
this program they i when i once was
talking with mitch mcconnell's national
security adviser on in regards to this
program his exact words were when it
comes to matters of immigration we wish
everyone had to go through the special
immigration visa program when we talk
about extreme vetting the sib program is
the gold standard those were his words
all right so this is a program that
republicans and democrats agree works
and has been very efficient at not
letting nefarious individuals in it
what i am arguing here and what i was
going after stephen miller for and i'll
get to it is that a backlog started in
the obama administration in its first
four years that after we got this law
fixed in 2013 and i'll review what those
changes were the program then started
functioning as designed and had it been
allowed to continue on the trump program
trump administration we wouldn't have
the problem we have right now in
afghanistan the reason why we have this
desperate rush is because we had such a
large backlog we had a backlog of around
almost 90 000 people at this point who
had been waiting for their visas on
average five to six years
just happens to coincide with the trump
administration right
if we had
processed their applications at the
manner with which they were being done
at the end of the obama administration
these people would have been in america
years ago and we wouldn't be having this
chaotic exit now so again the changes in
2013 were
we got
the
right to appeal their visa denial we got
them to give the right to know why their
visa had been denied
most importantly we got the law changed
so that the state department was
required by law to issue a decision on
their application within 270 days of
applying so they had nine months by law
to give them a decision and then we got
the cap increase from 1500 a year to 4
000 a year now
families families
from and i can now the numbers again
2013 to 2019 897 out of a total of 6 000
potential visas the numbers from 2014 to
are 4 000 families every single
year
we hit the cap every single year okay 4
000 families at the 4.4 mark
at the at the 2000 yeah yeah exactly the
4.4 mark got it yeah of the number of
people per family
then the trump administration comes in
the first year alone
the arrivals dropped by 2 000 families
the next year they dropped by another
thousand to fifteen hundred by the end
of the trump administration in this last
year under a hundred afghan families
come here in 2019 the international
refugee assistance project sues the
trump administration in federal court
and wins
for violating the 2013 national defense
author authorization act the one that we
were just talking about
the tenant that required the
government to process an applicant's
application within 270 days they proved
in federal court that the average length
of processing time is currently 800 days
we can now it wasn't that back during
the obama administration it got longer
during the trump administration and
that's where stephen miller comes in
because as soon as he got into
government there are
a myriad of articles out there on
politico they did an entire in-depth you
know axios um the daily caller the daily
beast they've all gone after him and
what they've shown is that he was
systematic in his
purposeful
uh
deconstruction and an evisceration of
the
overall refugee resettlement program in
the united states he set out to
dismantle it from within the government
to
push out career officials that had the
expertise to make this function properly
right who would normally have been
resisting his efforts to replace them
with willful sycophants who would do
whatever he wanted them to do
he
manipulated the the mechanism of
bureaucracy to such grind down the
issuance of visas that it became nearly
impossible for anyone to actually get
here right and the numbers show that
okay that's why the numbers drop off as
dramatically as they do but here's what
didn't change
afghans kept applying for the visa
in droves
and so what was a backlog of around 6
000 or so families when the obama
administration left office
ballooned to a backlog of 20 000
families by the time the byzan
administration took office and that's
why we have the massive
problem we might now do at the app
in kabul so
recognizing all of this was coming
in october of 2020
a lady by the name of kim stefiri who is
the founder the mama bear of the whole
movement was what we call her but she's
the founder of the association of
wartime allies
she calls me up
and she says matt it doesn't matter
who's going to win the election next
year
regardless who the president is we're
leaving afghanistan
and we've got to figure out a way to
start getting these people out now
because we're not going to be able to do
it at the 11th hour
and i said i agree with you kim
we need to sound the alarm and the way
that you do that in washington dc is you
write a white paper
so over the holidays she and i started
and sat down and we wrote a white paper
what we realized was in in reevaluating
the sid program at that point the
special immigration visa program
we learned that it just simply wasn't
functioning and what we needed to do was
prove to the administration that it was
so
hopelessly broken that the only real
means of saving these people with the
limited time that we had left was to
begin the largest airlift that has
occurred on this planet since the berlin
airlift in 1948 and this was critical
that we should start it immediately and
so as soon as the biotin administration
took office we sent that white paper
which was not publicly released at the
time we were trying to keep this private
we didn't want to sound the alarm we
didn't want to tip off the taliban
because our goal was not a chaotic exit
imagine
right now you see on television the
scenes at the airport in kabul that's
our other than what we call the trump
scenario which is just the complete
abandonment of these people to the evil
that are the taliban
this is the nightmare scenario a
collapse down to one airport in the
country where there's only one working
runway and we've told every afghan who
wants to believe a future under the
taliban that their only realistic chance
of doing that is to get to this x it
could not be more chaos than than this
right
what we had advocated for
back in february was the following so
let me take you through another
alternate earth where they paid
attention and listened to us
[Music]
back in february we controlled every
single airfield in afghanistan we
controlled the airfields in mazari
sharif herat jalalabad kandahar
uh helmand and lashkarga
um
you name it we held it bagram the
largest airport in the country we had it
all how many total
uh there were around 10 airfields that
we controlled back then
we all of them were the largest ones on
the country with honestly if we had
surged capacity that given the afghan
military hadn't collapsed the afghan
military held the rest of the remaining
airports there wasn't a single airport
held in the country by the taliban at
that point okay so think of it this way
if you go on wikipedia and you look up
every airport that's in afghanistan you
know there's a lot of them actually some
of them are just dirt airstrips right
c-130s and c-17s can land under
airstrips they're designed to do that
every one of those airstrips was under
the control of the afghan military that
had yet to collapse and a government
that was still functioning in place so
in this alternate scenario here's what
we propose they do
we gave them a list of names we said
these are all the people that you are we
are tracking that need your immediate
evacuation
imagine if they had started it then they
had started reaching out to the people
who were in the most furthest to hardest
reach areas the ones that they'd have to
helicopter and get out to and they'd fly
special operations teams in the dead of
night to pick up people and ferry them
back to air bases right imagine that if
they in the major cities they started
doing it in groups rather than just
telling everyone come to the airport at
once they did it alphabetically by name
all right or they did it by maybe when
they had first submitted their visa
application so that they're taking the
people who have been waiting in line the
longest right and they took it in
orderly chunks you could have managed it
in an efficient way where you were still
having total security not total security
because the taliban were dangerous and
obviously making trouble but way better
than security that you have now right
in this scenario we're moving people in
a regular clip during the winter when
it's not fighting season and the taliban
can't surge forces into the country and
only we truly have the ability to move
during winter right so you had a tiny
window you had a small window yeah we
had
not just a small window we had months
and we could have done that over months
we projected it out mathematically we
called it the devil's arithmetic we
actually plugged in we went and took the
average plane load the average passenger
load of a c5 a c17 a boeing triple seven
a dc 10 right because we've got a bunch
of those just like sitting in an area
and a bunch of 737s and we came up with
the average passenger load is about 228
people we can fit on one of those planes
overtake
we then took the number we divided it we
realized you need about 314 flights to
move all these people and if you're
going to do that you know over time it's
just an exponential thing right the
longer your runway the less time the
less flights per day you need the
shorter your runway the more flights
it's just math yep it's just math
and we handed it to them we handed it to
them on the silver platter we literally
said this is your evacuation plan here's
how to do it we even figured out how
much it was going to cost so in 1975 we
moved 130 000 vietnamese out of saigon
and in 1996 we airlifted 600 of our
kurdish allies out of northern iraq and
in 1999 we moved 20 000 of our coast of
our allies out of kosovo so we took
those historical evacuations as a as a
means to try to approximate cost
really critical point by the way the
1975 evacuation was by far the most
expensive because it was planned after
the fact it wasn't something that that
was planned for that's a lot of people
don't realize we didn't evacuate in a
planned way in vietnam it was chaotic it
was at the last moment
and congress had to allocate funds
afterwards which is why it was so
expensive the kurdish evacuation in 96
and the coast of our evacuation in 99
were planned for ahead of time and we're
an order of magnitude by a factor of
four cheaper so what we learned is if
you plan for it ahead of time you can
pay for it a lot more efficiently and
effectively than if you're trying to do
it now
so we extrapolated out the cost and what
it came down to is this it comes down to
about 700 million dollars
that's what we argued it cost 700
million dollars to move all 80 000 88 to
90 000 of these afghans that we're
tracking at that given time to the
island of guam
put them on the island temporarily
house them process them and then move
them off to other places in the united
states is exactly what we did in vietnam
now i should point out in vietnam we had
a couple of actual advantages that we
don't have in afghanistan the first is
we had an ocean to work with so
everybody there pretty much got put on
boats
you know that famous helicopter image in
vietnam that everyone talks about they
think it's taking off of the embassy
it's actually taking off of the cia
station
um it was the last helicopter out of
saigon
that helicopter didn't fly to the
airport it flew to a ship off to sea it
flew to an aircraft carrier because by
that point the north vietnamese had
overrun the airport in saigon
we don't have that luxury here in
afghanistan we're now seeing yep right
now
flights the day at work we're talking
about friday august the 20th
for 12 hours today flights stopped
coming in and out of the airport in
afghanistan because we ran out of pla we
ran out of space to put people in qatar
because that's where we've been flying
everybody to and they're just they just
don't have any more space to put people
so for the last 48 hours
our country has gone hand-in-hand to
every single other country on the planet
and asked them will you take our afghans
will you take our afghans for us
rather than
simply sending them to the island of
guam and this is what's so frustrating
the island of guam has requested that
these people be sent there the governor
of guam on june 12th publicly sent a
letter to the president formally
requesting that guam be used for this
evacuation yeah and that the island's
government began immediate consultations
with the federal government to begin
implementing this because they learned
that in the vietnam case and in the case
with the kurdish allies they were given
72 hours notice before people started
arriving on the island and they wanted
to start preparing it for as much as
possible here's the best part about the
guam option
guam's economy is dependent on tourism
and we all know that covet has just
wiped out tourism globally
guam currently has something like 30 000
hotel rooms sitting vacant
they're desperate to fill them
with at this point paying customers by
uncle sam right
here's a way to rescue the guam economy
because their federal aid package
literally runs out in 11 days which is
what the the island's economy has been
dependent on federal aid going back to
the beginning of cobit now that aid
package ends in 11 days the projection
is that the economy will completely
collapse and it could take five years to
recover unless there's another aid
infusion here's a way to not just give
them money but actually put people to
work and house a bunch of needy afghans
in the exact same way that we did in
saigon in 75 and you're probably asking
matt why aren't we doing this i'll tell
you why we're not doing this
the department of homeland security
wants the right to be able to deport
people who they don't want to be able to
bring into the united states
and the problem is is that we're not
screening anybody who's being put on
these planes other than to make sure
that they aren't wearing a suicide vest
and carrying weapons right we really
don't know that much about a lot of who
these people are
in some cases they're trying to get a
hold of that at the airport but the
lesson learned in vietnam was they
actually tried the same thing in vietnam
for the
the evacuation of vietnam
took place about over the course of two
weeks and they did a big post-mortem at
the end of it and what they learned was
that they should have tried to triage
people's visa status at the airport they
should have just been putting people on
planes and boats bringing them to a safe
haven and then triaging them there which
is what they're finally now doing in
afghanistan we've been arguing they
haven't been doing it for the last week
they're now finally doing it as of today
this is really important
we have a number of people now who are
going to be getting out that we just we
might not want to come here here the
same standard of screening that would
apply for the special immigration visa
program is clearly not being applied
here right
the reason why they don't want folks to
go to guam is they're afraid that anyone
who goes to guam they can't kick out
because u.s anti-torture statutes
stipulate that no one can be sent back
to a country that they have a reasonable
credible fear of being tortured upon
their return and any afghan is now going
to be able to claim that we had the same
problem in vietnam yeah of the 130 000
vietnamese that we brought out 1200 of
them
we didn't want coming here so you know
what we did we quietly made a deal with
other countries in the region to take
them they've never been allowed in the
united states we should be doing the
exact same thing now is that pretty easy
to do is that pretty easy to do
yes yeah guam is one plane flight away
from afghanistan they could do it on a
tank of gas the problem is right now so
you you've heard about all these private
charter flights that veterans are trying
to organize i'm part of that movement
it's we're calling it the digital
dunkirk it's veterans globally have just
come out and i don't mean military
veterans i mean diplomats aid workers if
you spent any time in afghanistan in the
last 20 years and you cared you you
either came out one of two people
you either came home and you said that
was interesting but it wasn't for me or
like the vast majority of us
you came home having left a part of your
soul back there and brought home part of
the people in its culture in your blood
that's why i keep saying it's not a
matter of us and them this is a matter
of us these are our people
matt let me ask you this october you and
kim write that white paper you send it
to them
did you ever hear back from anybody did
anybody call you did anybody nothing
nobody why
why do you think nobody reached out to
you
i don't know it'll be the thing that'll
haunt me for the rest of my life you
know when they finally did yesterday i
finally had a meeting with the head of
the task force ambassador jacobson
yesterday
that doesn't make any sense to me though
why wouldn't they why wouldn't they
reach out i don't think they took us the
only thing i can think of is either they
didn't take us seriously in which case
they are incompetent and inept or this
was willful that they didn't care
right it's either it's either a con it's
either a matter of they didn't they they
were inept and because again anybody
who's looked at afghanistan for the last
20 years knew that when we decided as of
april that was the key thing when biden
announced publicly that we had a
withdrawal he put a date on the calendar
and said this is when we're gone by then
we went public with our report
we published it we published the private
report in april i wrote an op-ed on
april 2nd in military times
i'm quoting myself now i said when
collapse occurs in afghanistan it will
happen faster than washington dc can
respond given afghanistan's unique
position in the world it's geopo
america's geopolitical relations with
some of its neighbors and the difficulty
of its terrain it will necessitate the
largest airlift since 1948 in order to
evacuate our afghan wartime allies and
to do that effectively and to prevent a
chaotic evacu exit we need to begin that
immediately i i published op-ed after
op-ed we were in time we were in
cnn we we created a website evacuate our
allies dot org it's been live since i
think june may we we built a bipartisan
coalition in congress
30 u.s senators on may 18th 15
republicans 15 democrats people like ron
johnson who does not think that the last
presidential election was legitimate and
patrick leahy who people think is a
socialist from vermont both of them
signed they don't agree on anything else
in dc they signed this letter together
option number seven on that letter
requested that the administration begin
the immediate evacuation of vulnerable
afghans
and they they did nothing
they had a bipartisan coalition in
congress calling for this you had
veterans and experts in the in the media
going public with this right they
wouldn't even take meetings with us and
so this is why
i am adamant that when this is all over
there have to be immediate hearings on
this we have to investigate this to
ensure it never happens again you know
you know in the business world they say
yeah we're going to come out with an mvp
or we're going to launch our product
right minimum viable product whatever
okay and sometimes the technology guys
will come back and they'll say guys i'm
telling you we're not ready to launch
right now if we do right now there's
going to be so many problems customers
are going to be unhappy it's going to
backfire on us i think we got to wait
three more months and sometimes the
entrepreneur is going to be like i think
we do it no matter what we had a
deadline we hit it and then you launch
it and then everything breaks and then
you lose your business right do you
think there is an element of no we have
to do it right now because we said we're
gonna do it right now let's announce it
let's go i know we're not prepared let's
just go and then all of a sudden becomes
a cluster or was it more
we don't think it's going to be that
problematic we don't think it's going to
be that big let's just go with it it's
the latter okay
we it was the we don't think we your
chicken lego your chicken little insane
the sky is falling and we we disagree
right we think the program we think the
visa program they said publicly in state
in testimony before congress we believe
that the special immigration visa
program is sufficient to move these
people by the end of our withdrawal date
they said it over and over and over
again and at that point they weren't
processing more than a couple hundred
visa applications a month with a backlog
of twenty thousand
now that the president of the united
states has said live on tv today that
any vulnerable afghan can get on a plane
you know how many people we're talking
about now it's well past that 90 000.
we're projecting at least a quarter
million people have got to be moved
from 92 quarter million yeah and how do
you throw them out down and now it's
even harder to filter people out correct
which is why the only thing that they
should be doing is trying to maximize
through look again it's a matter of
logistics i don't understand why they
don't call up the ceo of fedex and put
them in charge of doing this right like
if
honestly
they're going to tell the first thing
that the ceo of fedex is going to tell
the president united states sir you
don't have enough runway space
you're going to have to maximize
throughput we need more runway space i
know a number of runways right now that
aren't being utilized in afghanistan
bagram mazari sharif herat
kandahar
her uh helmand you know jalalabad
yeah they're currently held by the
taliban but my goodness we're the united
states of america
how much longer are we going to let
bullies and thugs dictate to us you know
what we're going to do like that's
that's kind of where i'm going to next
here's what i'm going to next in in the
interview with brian williams you said a
lot you said a lot in a 10-minute period
and he started off saying hey you know
it's got to be pretty honorable that our
president came up and he took
responsibility what do you think and you
just
opened up and you said we told them this
was going to happen nobody contacted us
but there's a part of it that you said
the taliban or the
are the same as the nazis i don't know
how you exactly said it but you compared
childhood to the nazis you know it seems
like when i watch the news some people
are saying well you know the late i
don't know what her name is with cnn or
msnbc she said she's very brave for
being out there in the middle
she said you know they're screaming to
be on back of a behind me death upon
america but they're also being very
respectful this is a pretty bizarre
situation and i say no we're gonna treat
women better we're gonna treat kids
better all that other stuff how much do
you believe that the taliban is going to
treat the afghani people better once we
leave them alone
i believe i would already know i have a
17 year old client that was taken last
night when he was getting groceries for
his parents
because his neighbors reported that his
mom and dad had planned to move to
america because his dad had been an
interpreter the guy hasn't been seen
since a 17 year old kid
i have video
video of our clients being shot in
kandahar in a mass grave
i mean literally they took a backhoe
they dug a mass grave the guy's head is
being pulled like this from his
literally they're pulling by his hair
and they throw him into a mass grave and
they shoot him
we know that they're going door to door
in cities right now outside of kabul and
they're disappearing people i have a guy
i'm going to be releasing it soon
a gentleman that i've been speaking to
in mazari sharif for weeks he and i have
been doing a private conversation just
one-on-one
he escaped mazari sharif in the most
audacious way uh he he snuck out by
trying to pretend he was a woman and hid
under a burqa and got on a bus and
somehow made it to kabul when he got to
kabul his neighbor called him and said
30 minutes after you left your house the
taliban raided your house looking for
you they said we've been told the
foreigner worked here someone who worked
with foreign forces lived in this home
you need to come with us you know what
this guy's job was
he was the i.t guy
he's the i.t guy they're trying to kill
the i.t guy
i wasn't being hyperbolic when i said
that they're going up after even the
people who collected our trash right
because you have to understand it from
the taliban's perspective
we spent the last year kicking their
butt and killing them killing them and
their family members they want revenge
for anyone who helped us do that it's in
there
there's this there's this code of honor
called pashtun wally it's like a code of
conduct amongst them it stipulates that
if anyone dishonored your family the
only way to reclaim your honor is to
take violence upon them or you want to
be paid what's your vision what is the
taliban's vision
the paladin's vision is they were
establishing an islamic caliphate
which is what the islamic state tried to
do in iraq
i i this
again taliban 1.0 and 2.0 are the exact
same thing with one key difference you
know what it is here's the difference
taliban 1.0 inherited a country that was
in ruins okay it had been a country that
the soviets had bombed and then the
afghans had fought themselves and
literally it was in rubble they had a
couple of working tanks
taliban 2.0 has divisions worth of
american military equipment and hum raps
envies you see all their fighters are
armed with american-made m4s with 1200
acogs you know scopes on them
they have
arms drones that cost 3.4 million
dollars per drone they have attack
aircraft fighter jets the modern day
version of a p-51 mustang
they have more helicopters than 166
nations on the planet to include the
country of australia which is a nato
ally they're one of the most heavily
armed powers in the region
yeah
and here's what i don't understand then
how does a president biden with the
intel that he has
say the afghan military has three
hundred thousand uh taliban has only
seventy five thousand they're going to
be fine we'll train them they're they're
good that's the thing is the forces i
just gave you are all of the forces the
taliban just inherited when the afghan
government collapsed and they took over
what they had was this they probably had
about 70 000 fighters and the afghan
army had been attributed that 300 000
number was probably true as of a couple
of years ago but you have to understand
that in one year the afghan military
would suffer more casualties than we did
in 20.
let me let me let me give you a really
specific detail okay
wow
70 000 afghan soldiers have died
fighting the taliban in the last 20
years 70 000
that we know of
when we used to do the memorial service
in afghanistan because we were allied
nations
we would do it weekly they would come
out and they would read the names of of
the the people who died and you know
each pers each person you know they did
this at isaf headquarters
in kabul
and they would i'm told what they do is
the the americans get up the american
read the names of the americans who died
that week and the brits you know
governmental officials get up and do the
same thing and on down the line
the person who went last was the
government official from the islamic
republic of afghanistan
they didn't read a list of names they
just got up and said a number
because if they read those names they
would have been there for hours
that's how many casualties they were
taking weekly
matt again going back to it isn't your
intel supposed to give you isn't
your whoever is whoever you have on your
administration supposed to give you this
information where you make an educated
decision on what to do next
again you see that the president united
states up today still spewing
[ __ ] claiming that american citizens
there's there's been you know very
limited instances of american citizens
who are being stopped by the taliban you
know that they should just be they've
made a deal that the taliban are
supposed to let them do the checkpoint
right after he did that abc news went
live to one of their correspondents was
like i was with a u.s citizen who got
beaten by the taliban they were showing
them their passports that were being
denied being able to get through the
checkpoints
why are we again you know who tried to
you know who negotiated with the taliban
the trump administration you know how
the taliban had suddenly a ton of
strength that they were able to do this
because the trump administration
negotiated the release of 5 000 of their
most lethal fighters and leaders those
people as soon as they got released went
back and planned this military coup and
takeover of afghanistan the trump
administration is as much to blame for
what happened here as the abided
administration the trump administration
planted the siege and set this whole
horrible train derailment in motion the
biden administration's pro
has the blame for not having listened to
us and having planned the proper
evacuation of these people in the first
place again why did we ever take a
single service member out of afghanistan
before we moved our vulnerable afghans
will be the thing that haunts me till i
die
that is gonna be the question that i'll
take with me to my grave what do you say
to those that we look this has been
going on for for four uh
presidencies right let's just say with
two republicans two democrats you hear
everybody talk about it's been 20 years
trillions of dollars etc etc this many
labs we've seen all the statistics over
and over and over again
we went in for al qaeda we went in for
bin laden right okay so bin laden has
gone up pakistan uh al qaeda scored away
some are saying why are we still there
why are we still there having all this
money why and by the way this is not a
republican or a democratic thing there's
a lot of people that are saying on both
sides let's just leave already
and then there's another community that
is saying look if you do leave just so
you know they're going to turn us into a
training center they're going to turn us
into a recruiting camp this thing's not
gonna change in decades there it's a
mindset it's a mentality that they have
you're gonna make a big mistake leaving
this place and all these soldiers that
lost their lives are sitting there
saying what the hell did i do serving
all these tours in this place so what do
you say to both sides i say this i say
the mistake goes back to the bush
administration i think we should have
been the the you know george w he should
have just sat down with the american
people and said this is going to take a
long time these people need to be
developed and educated
the way that we're going to win in
afghanistan is by the number of women we
teach to read that has been the metric
that i've cared about the most and let
me explain why the gentleman who saved
my life
janice the morning after he did it i met
him in the chow hall our dining facility
on a little lap he was he was eating by
himself
i walked over to him you have to
understand this guy was a stranger to me
i didn't i've been in afghanistan for
two weeks at that point i had met him 10
days prior in a receiving line we had
set up all of two sentences to each
other hi my name is so-and-so and i look
forward to working with you that's it
[Music]
he's sitting there even by himself and
sit down and i say hey man can i join
you says sure i said let me ask you
something
you say my life yesterday i don't
understand you don't even know me you're
a complete stranger why'd you do it
why'd you kill those two guys
and he said well you're a guest in my
country i take the bullet before you
and i said well you're a hell of a shot
i'm really glad you're on our side
but why are you on our side and he
looked at me because you know nothing
about afghans and i said you're right
will you teach me he said okay first
lesson
afghan men can't fight without the
blessings of their mothers
i said are you telling me that everybody
on the other side of yesterday's battle
had mom's permission to be there he said
yeah they sure do i said well which
makes your mom so much more enlightened
than their mom he said oh that's simple
my mom
can read and write for herself she's
literate she's read the quran for
herself she knows what they preaches in
islam is [ __ ] that's why she forbade
me from ever joining them and then he
looked at me and got really serious he
said why do you think they burned down
girls schools it's because they're
afraid of an afghanistan filled with
moms like mine because then their
movement dies
that's the metric i've cared about the
most
so yeah the taliban might claim that
they're allowing women to be on tv in
kabul but in every other city they've
been banned from public life
banned from public life everywhere the
burqa is back across afghanistan you
want to know what afghanistan is going
to look like after we leave just go
outside of kabul
right
so the so what of all this is
it
there was a british conservative member
a conservative mp a british member of
parliament named tom
too hat i think i can't pronounce his
last name tom something or another
who just gave one of the most
impassioned speeches on this whole topic
on the floor of the british parliament
yesterday it's going viral amongst the
the digital dunkirk army the the online
community of veterans that have
mobilized and are literally i'm doing a
deployment from my office in my home
right now from my living room right i
just weighed myself this morning i've
lost 11 pounds from last week like it's
i'm not i i tried to count up the number
of hours of sleep i think i've slept
20 hours in six days i think was when i
was at
we are
desperate to save these people because
they're our brothers and sisters and
this guy even though he's an elected
member of parliament he's a british
military veteran of the afghan war
and
he
so eloquently
stated how we all feel
about these people
and
he talked about
you know the
the the need to to keep a promise
and
the the the problems with this chaotic
exit and the fact that it was
unilaterally determined that we didn't
even talk and consult with our allies
about this right and nato is pissed this
is a serious consequence of this nato is
furious at this
one of the most important parts of his
speech however was he talked about the
need for what he called everyone talks
about forever wars he wanted to talk
about forever peace
and he made the argument that he said
yeah we spent a lot of money in
afghanistan but it wasn't this bad
we had gotten it down to the point where
there were 2500 us troops
that were holding back this dam
and that and i i would argue that while
that dam was being held
we were teaching a lot of girls to read
a lot of girls
change is hard it takes time it's slow
democracy is messy we aren't even
getting it right in our own country
right look at our last four years look
at just the last you know
eight months right going back to just
january 6th a seminal moment now for our
nation's history ever democracy is hard
even after how many 200 almost in 230
years we're still not quite perfect yet
but we're trying it's crazy you're
saying that john adams once said there
was uh never a democracy yet that didn't
commit suicide
yeah it was never a democracy that
didn't yet commit suicide are we are we
kind of like uh
have we lost our way have we lost what
this great country was founded on where
a guy like me who
escaped iran after living there for 10
years goes to germany lives in a refugee
camp comes to the states serves at the
101st airborne this american dream to me
of watching rocky and sylvester stallone
if he can change and i can change
anybody can change man one day i want to
come to this great country where there's
ghostbusters and there's gremlins and
all this other stuff and now it's kind
of like people around the world are
watching saying is america still america
yeah man it is because let me tell you
about my brother janice so my brother
janice the guy who saved my life you
know how you he learned how to speak
english
he watched uh so janice and his family
they're in afghanistan and you don't
understand his life is just collapsed
after collapse after collapse
and he ends up spending seven years in a
refugee camp in pakistan where 27
members and his family are all put into
one like one one room apartment
they're so poor
that it takes a couple of months for
them to save up enough money to buy a tv
vcr combo remember those the tvbcr combo
and they buy it off like a guy at like
his like house and he said look
the vcr works it stops it plays it
pauses it rewinds it fast forwards it
just doesn't eject so whatever the movie
is in the thing is the one movie you get
to watch
you know what the movie was what's that
commando that's how janice learned how
to speak english
he watched commando over and over and
over and over and he was like those guys
are cool i want to be like those guys he
saw he saw pop pop culture right
janice now owns a house
provides for his family
his friend ajmal fakheri ajmal arrived
in this country on
january 1st 2014 new year's eve day
there was no one there to greet him at
the airport in san francisco when he
arrived because nobody knew he was
coming because the state department had
given him a 72-hour visa and dared him
to get to america before it expired and
ajmal somehow sold everything in kabul
packed the wife and the you know
four-year-old son the two-year-old kid
onto a plane with they're allowed to
bring one bag per person it has to be
under 50 pounds and fit in an overhead
flight bin i mean it's just crazy right
they fly to the united states they get
here with 29 minutes to spare before
their visa expires that's when they
cleared customs 11 31 pm on december
31st 2013.
osmal turns to an officer at the san
francisco airport and says
i don't know where to go what do i do
next the guy goes airport's closing kid
it's gonna be midnight it's gonna be
holiday it's new year's eve
i don't know where to send you but
there's homeless shelters up in the city
i suggest you go there
osmal his wife four year old son
two-year-old daughter then walk up the
101 freeway from san francisco airport
to downtown san francisco where for the
next week they live on the streets
a week into this existence ajmal's wife
is giving reading him the riot act in
dari you know you son of a [ __ ] i can't
believe you got it we used to have a
house and blah blah blah now
what the hell did you think you were
doing we had a life back there
she's giving him just the business when
an afghan american who had
immigrated as part of the first diaspora
in the mid-80s most of them settled in
the greater san francisco
area in fremont california
walks by and hears ajmal getting yelled
at and his native tongue and stops and
says you know dude why are you on the
street begging for food
and ajmal tells him his whole story i
was an interpreter i got over here i'm
supposed to have assistance no one's
helping me can you help me
he says do you know anyone in america
and he goes yeah i know this guy named
janice
my janice wow
he lives in virginia
can you help me get there he goes do you
know janice's number he goes no he's all
right we'll come back to my place so
ojamal moves into this guy for about a
week
and they start calling back to
afghanistan trying to get janus his
number because janus has only just
arrived here a couple of weeks earlier
no one knows his new u.s number yet
he finally gets a hold of janice who's
standing next to me and janice turns to
me and says you know that money we we
raised and how we want to start that
organization can we make him the first
case i said sure so we fly ojmal from
san francisco to dc we get them an
apartment we put them up we get them
started ajmal's first job was delivering
pizzas for dominoes wow ajmal is now one
of the largest real estate agents in dc
he's mogul he employs a company i think
of about 10 or 11 other real estate
agents most of whom are now afghans and
the afghans who moved to dc exclusively
buy their homes through fakiri real
estate these people aren't coming to
take our jobs they're coming to create
them by the butler right i love that
they are the most entrepreneurial
industrious wonderful people on the
planet i keep telling folks i want
people to befriend them they will enrich
and welcome your life if you if you get
to know these people i guarantee you
they will be guests at your thanksgiving
dinner table and you will join them for
iftahar during ramadan like that's how
close they're gonna become to you i got
two last questions for you before we
wrap up here's one sure if the chances
of 9 11 attack since 20-year anniversary
is coming up did the chances of that
increase in the last two weeks
absolutely by how much
i
exponentially as soon as we leave that
got it okay second question
is there's a camp that says look during
the no matter how much you hate the guy
and you know there's a group that loves
him there's a group that hates him when
he was president for four years he was
able to unite palestine israel he was
able to you know we didn't hear anything
about his isis he was able to sit down
with the biggest enemies and
talk to them taliban north korea all
this other stuff there was no major war
or conflicts like this during the four
years yes covet but not war what do you
say to those who say if trump was around
today this wouldn't have happened
you say you're literally you're
delusional
we're worse
that he shouldn't have been talking to
half of those people none of those
conversations amounted to anything what
did we get out of north korea nothing we
got nothing out of those conversations
other than making the north korean
regime look good look at what like so
again the fact that we had this taliban
take over is because of the trump
administration's willingness to
negotiate with thugs the taliban are not
a legitimate government they weren't
democratically elected they just
orchestrated a coup and the reason why
they were able to do that was because
mike pompeo at the instructions of
donald trump allowed them to have this
deal when the when they signed the deal
in doha you know what happened
this is this is eyewitness accounts from
my friend jp lawrence who was in the
room when they signed it in doha he just
wrote about it on stars and stripes
online the taliban pulled out phones and
started taking selfies with each other
high-fiving hooping it up because they
knew they just got the deal of a
lifetime they had just won we had just
capitulated trump negotiated our
surrender you know what pompeo had to
tell them on the way out
he said his last remarks when he was
leaving the room was guys just try and
keep the violence to a minimum as you do
this we need we get that you got what
you wanted but don't make it like too
bad for us are you kidding me
are you kidding me
this is the what the bite administration
is doing right now is the failure there
is continuing to take the trump doctrine
and run with it we shouldn't negotiate
with the taliban we shouldn't have
honored this deal they weren't a
legitimate government no one elected so
so any hold on no this is key mullah
berater was never elected by anybody to
be the head of that organization if the
taliban really wanted to take over
afghanistan they should have run for
election in the next they should have
won for office in the next election so
matt question for you you seem like a
pretty reasonable gun obviously you said
on the brian williams that you voted for
biden you called them out so it's not
like you voted for trump that's pretty
obvious but you you know you voted for
him and you call a guy out now would you
say cuba is a uh uh democracy
no okay it should be yeah well what and
it suffers under the communist people i
agree
you don't like it when you see a trump
go sit down with the north korean
president or obama go sit down with
castro in uh cuba for three days and go
watch a baseball game together and have
fun i so let me tell you something i i
had a lot of problems with that okay
right i think the american presidency is
a sacred office and it shouldn't be
pimped out to dictators got it right if
you're going to meet with a dictator
you better be doing something like nixon
did which is opening up all of china
right like you need it needs to you need
to be getting something like if you're
going to sit down with fidel castro you
don't just get an embassy right you get
the communist party to allow for free
and fair elections right because fidel
castro has been trying to kill americans
for he did for half a century yeah right
the the the cuban regime is horrifically
oppressive to its people right and thank
god the america the united states of
america is about 90 miles away and has
welcomed so many of its refugees
which president did it right who's the
last president that did it right with
cuba no no just just not even cuba give
me the last president that foreign
policy did it right like you would say
oh you're going that far give me 40
years last 40 years i don't know if any
of them did probably george h.w bush
george walker bush was probably our best
our best foreign policy president are
you from the school of thought that a
president needs to a commander or a
chief needs to be somebody that's served
in the military
no okay got it matt uh uh first of all
do you have a podcast or no i do it's
called wartime allies we interview uh
the people who are these people like
we're interviewing them live on the
ground right now so we're going to put
the link below there we're going to put
the link to your twitter
uh what a fantastic conversation i know
more about what's going on there just by
having a conversation with you i hope
the audience enjoyed it just as much as
i'd appreciate you for coming on but
this was great thanks for having me i
please let me know when this is out
because you're the first people that
asked me to give this in detail and i
feel like i just kind of gave the world
the dissertation they need i'm gonna get
my guys on it right now we're gonna try
to turn it around next two to three
hours i'll send it to you and then we
can share it with the world i would love
to meet you at some point by the way
sorry if you ever come up to dc or
or whatnot i might be down in orlando in
a couple of months we'll have to see how
my schedule plays out i'll treat you
dinner we'll we'll do red carpet
treatment for you awesome i love it i
love it appreciate you buddy thank you
so much thank you so much anytime
bye what do you agree with matt or not
this was probably the most thorough
breakdown of what's really going on in
the history of afghanistan taliban and
different presidents how they handled
the situation curious to know what you
took away from the comment below if you
like to put a thumbs up and subscribe to
the channel and on top of that if you
enjoyed this interview i did an
interview with a former taliban member
that turned mi6 that gave the life of a
taliban who was there directly with
osama bin laden that's a fascinating
story if you've never heard it click
over here to watch it take care
everybody bye
[Music]